Speaker 1: I want to address a series
of articles that people sent me,
each in its own way, sort of saying Trump could
really be going down for some crimes here.
OK, now I'm going to give you my conclusion
up front. The most likely scenario is this
stuff doesn't happen. But there have been
enough articles and enough people wrote
to me that I want to tell you what's being
said and you've got to look at the language.
A Business Insider article. Donald
Trump could be charged with multiple
election multiple crimes over his attempts to
overturn his loss in Georgia, a report says.
The article saying the report by the Brookings
Institution, a think tank in Washington, D.C.,
analyzed publicly available evidence that showed
Trump and his allies attempted to pressure Georgia
officials to change the lawful outcome of the
election. A key piece of evidence is the now
infamous Trump call, where he wanted to find
eleven thousand seven hundred and eighty votes.
There's no way I lost Georgia. There's no
way we won by hundreds of thousands of votes.
Those assertions were, of course, false. And
the report added that Trump publicly pressured
and contacted Republican officials to ask for
their help. We conduct we conclude that Trump's
post-election conduct in Georgia leaves him
at substantial risk of possible state charges
predicated on multiple crimes. These charges
potentially include criminal solicitation
to commit fraud, election fraud, intentional
interference with performance of election duties,
conspiracy to commit election fraud,
criminal solicitation and state RICO
violations, the report adds liability
could extend to allies like Rudy Giuliani.
Another article from Vanity Fair says report Trump
may be hit with multiple criminal charges over
his effort to overturn the election in Georgia.
This is by best someone who's done a lot of great
coverage over the years. It references the exact
same report from the Brookings Institution and
it mentions the request to find eleven thousand
seven hundred and eighty votes. It refers to Trump
pressure that happened publicly and privately
against Republican officials. And it again says
Trump could be hit with that same list of charges
based on the same Brookings Institution report.
And then lastly from The Detroit News, Trump
faces substantial legal risk in Georgia case.
Think Tank Report says this is from that same
Brookings Institution report and it lists the
exact same stuff. So basic media literacy, first
things first. All of these articles are really one
story. The Brookings Institution's opinion is
Trump could face substantial legal problems.
What needs to be clarified is if he were a normal
person. I continue to see no appetite in charging
Trump for what he did in Georgia. Should he
be charged? Yeah. Yeah. Could he be charged?
Absolutely. The ongoing question is less about
could or should it happen, but will it happen now?
You can look at Georgia and you can say, well,
on the one hand, Republicans control basically
everything in Georgia, but they don't control
the Senate seats. But that is not involved. So
as I hit my mike, sorry, that is not involved
here. We're talking about state charges here.
And Republicans in Georgia aren't going to hold
Donald Trump accountable for anything. He operates
with impunity. It's infuriating, but it's just
not going to happen. The other side of it is that,
you know, the truth is these elected officials
in Georgia don't actually have anything to do
with what is is happening. It's
really the Fulton County D.A.
and the Fulton County D.A. has
experience with organized crime
and may not be beholden to the political
interests of state Republicans in Georgia.
I don't know the answer. My continued belief
is Trump's not going down. Allies might.
Other people might. I don't see Trump going
down. If you disagree with me, let me know.